[Music]
one of the middle east's bloodiest
conflicts is also one of its most
overlooked
it's not syria or iraq it's in a
different place entirely
yemen the 20 month old civil war there
has killed more than 10 000 people and
triggered a massive humanitarian crisis
but press coverage has been minimal
overshadowed by the fight against isis
in syria and in iraq in yemen one side
has houthi rebels backed by iran
on the other you have the former yemeni
government of abderbuh
mansour al-hadi backed by a coalition of
10 countries led by neighboring saudi
arabia who was ultimately also backed by
the u.s
the civil war there erupted in 2015
when the houthis a shiite group who
received money and weapons from iran
took up arms to overthrow yemen's
government which is sunni
and backed by saudi arabia the houthis
complained that the government
discriminated against them for years
mistreating them on a large scale
and that their fight is a fight to be
treated fairly
many in the region by contrast see it
very differently they think it's the
latest front
in a shadow war between saudi arabia and
iran
for control over the entire region in
march of 2015
saudi arabia began bombing houthi-held
territory
across yemen causing mass civilian
casualties
they've destroyed targets ranging from
marketplaces to hospitals
from schools and even to a funeral
recently
where 140 people were killed in a single
strike
in august the saudis bombed the vital
port of hodeidah
severely damaging a main source of
yemen's food and humanitarian aid
shipments
and increasing the chances of mass
starvation in what is already an
impoverished country
the indiscriminate bombing has prompted
investigations by the un
for possible war crimes but while the
saudis are leading this bloody
campaign the blame also spreads to a
great power who support us directly
contributing to the carnage to the
united states the us has supported saudi
arabia
militarily since world war ii selling
arms
providing military aid and training the
saudi military on how to use u.s
manufactured
planes tanks and other weapons in recent
years
saudi arabia has bought more weapons
from the u.s than any other country in
the world
just since march of 2015 the u.s has
authorized 22 billion dollars worth of
weapons sales in saudi arabia
the most recent deal includes 20 abrams
tanks
listed as battle damage replacements
the battle of course is yemen
the weapons the u.s sells also include
cluster bombs
banned by most of the international
community and f-15 fighter planes
which is making up the vast bulk of what
the saudi air force is currently
using as it bombs yemen but america's
aid to saudi arabia
goes way beyond weapon sales and it's
directly contributing to the current
fight
that's because washington is literally
helping to refuel saudi planes
while they strike targets across yemen
when the saudis asked the us to refuel
one of their planes
giant american tankers like the kc-135
stratotanker
take off from the incirlik air base in
turkey or from u.s carriers in the
arabian sea
they then link up with saudi f-15s in
international airspace
these airborne refuels give the saudi
planes a much longer range
and allow saudi's air campaign to become
more lethal because the plane can stay
in the air longer
and hit targets much more frequently as
of late november
the us had flown more than 1600
refueling missions
to over 6300 aircraft in the skies
bombing yemen that's an average of two a
day
so why is the u.s so supportive of this
bloody campaign the most important
reason
is the iran nuclear deal in 2015 the
obama administration
offered to drop its crippling economic
sanctions on iran
in exchange for iran limiting its
nuclear program
without those sanctions iran's political
and economic power has significantly
increased
making saudi arabia nervous that their
enemy will gain new influence in the
region
in countries from iraq to lebanon and
from syria
to yemen now that iranian influence is
in saudi arabia's backyard the saudis
fear that houthi rebels loyal to iran
will now be literally on the footsteps
of their country they want us help
beating them back
secondly the intervention in yemen is
also a part of the us's broader
counter-terrorist strategy for the
middle east
the goal of u.s policy in yemen is to
make sure that yemen cannot be a safe
haven
that extremists can use to attack the
west and to attack the united states
yemen is home to the most active and
dangerous branch of al qaeda
the us has a major interest in
preventing this terror group
from taking advantage of the power
vacuum in yemen to plot new attacks
finally the us is honoring one of its
longest standing most important allies
since world war ii saudi arabia has been
a vital partner against communism
and now terrorism the yemen campaign is
a high priority for saudi arabia
and that makes it a priority for the
united states but as the war devolves
into a bloody stalemate
the administration is increasingly
worried about being complicit in
potential war crimes
and state department documents obtained
by reuters a meeting agenda from january
of 2016
talks about limiting exposure to loac
which means the law of armed conflict
some in the white house worry that the
us was potentially violating that law
because of its assistance to saudi
arabia in those documents
state department officials also
discussed the implications of a 2013
international court decision implying
that if the u.s were to provide
practical assistance encouragement or
moral support to the saudis
the u.s could be charged with war crimes
itself in an effort to avoid this
the u.s issued a no strike list to the
saudis to try to mitigate civilian
casualties
it included things like known hospitals
universities
schools cemeteries the saudis appear to
be ignoring it
the un estimates 10 000 people have died
in the fighting
that 370 000 children are malnourished
and that 10 thousand other children have
already died from preventable disease
nearly three million people have been
pushed out of their homes in the last
year of fighting alone
truces have come and gone while hopes
for peace talks falter
the houthis continue to run the
government in the capital of sanaa
raising questions about what saudi
arabia has actually accomplished
and whether any of it could possibly be
worth the cost
here at home in congress some lawmakers
from both parties have talked about
stopping weapons sales to saudi
arabia until does more to keep the air
war in yemen from causing massive human
rights abuses
others argue that america's relationship
with saudi arabia is so important
that the u.s needs to keep selling
weapons despite the carnage in yemen
the obama administration for its part
has repeatedly urged the saudis
to do more to avoid accidentally hitting
targets like schools and like hospitals
the white house has also condemned
individual attacks
but the reality is that the us finds
itself increasingly complicit
with the actions of a coalition led by
saudi arabia
that means president obama will leave
office with america helping an ally
fight a bloody war
causing mass civilian suffering that
shows no signs of ending
and that is not a legacy to be proud